Will a new migration pact put an end to asylum in Spain?
Unfortunately I have had to hear this and
have had to see it on several occasions.
For you,
my Spanish-speaking brother,
I want to give you some key points that you have to
understand about what is being considered in this migration
pact because so far it is in phases and it is not yet at 100x100.
In Europe there is a migratory difficulty with the brothers from Africa?
Most of the African countries that have a coastline on
the Mediterranean come to Europe to Spain because in the
Canary Islands it is one of those that has more problems,
even Italy and Greece illegally.
You Hispanic brother without putting in Cuban Bolivian
Ecuadorians Dominican Republic who need a visa to come to Spain?
You enter this country legally You enter as a tourist and there is
a law on foreigners that is very clear and that talks about asylum
and we all have the right to apply for asylum I am not telling you
that you will be approved because 90 percent will deny it but
there are beliefs There are people who say I cannot apply for asylum.
Well because I am the most beautiful of all In the asylum you have to give a
story where you express your fear of losing your life because of the state.
That is a very important fact that you have to do
when making your application and this is not a miracle.
What asylum will allow you is to be on a regular basis.
Anyone who wants to wait years because someone told them that they have
to wait years to be on a regular basis is already a very personal decision.
But if you want to have the shortcuts of the law,
asylum that in Spain does not give you protection,
you do not get pay but it allows you a work permit because what we
want is to join this society by contributing and working formally.
My question is why wait so many years to be on a regular basis if there is a
law on foreigners that has given these mechanisms
to make people eligible for it?
about the migration pact at this time
because we are not being asked for a visa,
much less.
This is more in reference to the brothers in Africa and from the
terrible thing I could observe they spoke as a negotiation point,
a country that all these people who arrive illegally
have to share and whoever does not want it simply pays.
Unfortunately,
this is how politicians work.
But brother Hispanic who speaks my same language,
don't worry about those in-depth analyses
of those political scientists who do not,
this is towards a specific end for us.
So far it remains the same and if you apply for asylum you
already have the important tips so that you are not irregularly?